championnat du monde féminin 2015 nous
sommes donc en 16e de finale et nous
allons suivre bien évidemment le match
de marie sebag assez bas qui donc s'est
qualifié en 32e de finale assez
facilement on l'a vu alors que sophie
millet s'est fait battre par irina crush
donc marie qui a battu la chinoise liu
wang donc la voici en 16e de finale face
à l'ukrainienne anna ou chez nina donc
qui a un très bon niveau et l'oim pas
loin de mille cinq cents lots et mesmari
aussi et marie a été classé plus plus
loin avec un meilleur classement déjà
dans le passé
donc elle part quand même légèrement
favorite sans doute de ce match mais un
match quand même extrêmement équilibrée
donc on va voir comment débute ces 16e
de finale avec les blancs pour marie
face donc à un as ou chez nina démarre
avec les blancs c'est considérer un peu
moins bien que de jouer les blancs
second puisque bien sûr avec les blancs
second on peut toujours espérer revenir
au score en cas de défaite est donc la
première partie il faut surtout faire
attention à ne pas perdre
c'est un principe qu'on retrouve aussi
dans le football et en général dans les
matches comme ça en aller retour quel
que soit le sport il vaut mieux recevoir
en 2d mais là bon et bien sûr on peut
pas avoir tout les match en sa faveur
est donc ici c'est les blancs en premier
pour marie qui débute par eux quatre ans
là c'est parti donc que 4 ne varie pas
du premier match avec les blancs puisque
j'ai joué aussi le coût de 4 alors ces
cinq sicilienne cavaliers f3 clavel et
c6 est là que va jouer marie c3 donc
c'est là même qu'elle n'a vous avez joué
en 32e de finale avec les blancs
voilà le cette fameuse sicilienne qu'on
appelle variante à la pine qui jouent
ces trois pour le voit ici en fait
contrôler la case des quatre contrôles
ici et qui permet aux blancs d'envisager
évidemment de pousser des 400 sans
problème ca c c'est une variante solide
pour jouer le centre voilà mais ça
permet pas d'aller très vite par contre
c'est un peu un peu rampant comme
ouverture donc qu'avec six logique on en
profite du fait que comme les noix les
blancs ont joué ses trois on peut pas
jouer le cavalier bien sûr en défense du
point 4
donc on la taxe aux pions et on lève et
l'invita à pousser ce que fait marc y
voilà c'est normal et en se faisant donc
on va être fort sur glace noire
puisqu'on avant une belle chaîne de
pions b2c 3 des 4 5 mais un peu plus
faible sur les cases blanches une
critique assez longue mais du coup il
n'y a pas de plan qui attaquent ces
cases et donc sont un peu plus faibles
donc les noirs ils vont tranquillement
calé des cinq des quatre s'éprend des
quatre est alors dans la partie
précédente
maria jouer ici le coup ces quatre
puisque on n'est pas pressé
de prendre en des cas puisque le nord
peuvent apprendre puisque le cavalier
des cinq serait emprise de la dame et
l'a donc la préfère prendre tout
simplement
c'est pendant les quatre des six
normales on met pression sur le sur le
centre tous ces quatre maintenant bon ça
ne change pas grand-chose et dé prendre
cinq échanges tout de suite directe à
pourquoi pas alors après des princes 1
qui est logique on reprend pourquoi on
reprend du piaui pourrait vite avant un
pion isolé sinon le pion des quatre
cerise au lait donc là avec des premiers
cinq bombes et il rejoint ce pion ses
petits copains ici là c'est à dire que
plus tard on pourra jouer f2f 4 pour le
protéger et ici cavaliers des en b 4
alors ça doit être très théorie tout ça
bien sûr vis-à-vis d'am-dam et donc
c'est alors ça c'est un coup c'est un
coup intéressant qui semble assez fort
pour les premiers noirs assez efficace
d4 ici et là donc proposé un échange de
da mais bon si les noirs dans cette
première partie chercher s'ils peuvent
obtenir une nulle ils sont content bien
sûr puisque ils ont les blancs dans la
deuxième dame b3 pour marié donc évite
les changes de dames logique et petites
batteries dame fou qui vise regardez
donc ici hausse est bon en même temps
vous me direz le calais b 4ème peut
attaquer mais bien sûr il est protégé
par son collègue sa c2 cavalli qui se
protège très bien pas de problème donc
dame b3 force ou coup suivant mémoire
illogique pas de problème de 6
voilà terminé il ya plus d attaques sur
cette diagonale
c'est extrêmement solide et en même
temps montré que ça prépare le
développement du fouet fuite et le rock
qui suit petit rock de la part des
blancs très bien et là forcément petit
rock jeu sur j'accélère mon
développement mais est bien les noirs se
presse pas il aurait pu jouer aussi
fawcett près par l'europe mais non il ya
un petit coup intéressant intermédiaires
qui est pas très très risqué cavaliers à
5 fourchette dame fou c'est une pseudo
fourchette ce qu'on va voir le truc et
en profite du fait que quand on a joué
six bien sûr le cavalier b4 et protégé
par le faut et suit donc ce fou protège
le cavalier donc ya pas de pas de menace
sur ce calibre 4 on en profite donc avec
aléas scène pour faire une petite
fourchette et perturber le développement
des blancs donc là sa force un la suite
on va pas jouer la dame et permettre
cavaliers prend fou qui ne nomme pas
forcément bien placés en c4 derrière et
puis on aurait donné surtout la paire de
fou non non on fait tous mes cinq échecs
ont sans perdre de temps voilà faut que
les noirs par l'échec est logique mais
sur ces fous 17
la dame continue d'être attaqué et on
propose un échange de
de fou alors le coup suivant est
quasiment obligé aussi de la part des
blancs bon on pourrait aussi jouer fou
prendre dès cet échec d'un prend mais ça
serait mieux pour les noirs puisque on
permet au noir de se développer de
sortir leurs dames
il pourrait même envisager de faire le
grand roque que derrière il aurait pu
sortir on accélérer le développement des
noirs donc c'est mieux ce que je marie
bien sûr damas quatre voies la dame à 4
la maintenance et la dame est pas sorti
en plus elle peut pas aller où il veut
puisqu'il faut continuer à protéger 17
ou alors faire ce que fait et bien ou
chez nina ici c'est à dire que le fait
fou prend b5 tranquillement d'un pro b 5
échecs et cavaliers ans et 6 alors ça
paraît douteuse puisque on se dit oui
mais attention les blancs peuvent
prendre en 17
et effectivement les blancs peuvent
prendre un b 7 mai les noirs ici
regardez on te coups gagnants facile
voilà faites vous la main en 30 secondes
très simplement tombé 8 et la dame a
plus de gaz
regardez cette dame elle est prise prise
prise prise tout ça est contrôlé par les
noirs en 7 c'est contrôlé par le
cavalier c6 le cavaly c6 est contrôlé
par le cavalier b4 toute la colonne ici
bien sûr est en prise delà de la tour et
enfin la casa 6 est aussi contrôlé par
le cavalier b4 donc voyez que la dame
ici est prise voilà donc ce pion on
appelle ça ce pion est empoisonnée voilà
ces astuces de ce début très
certainement après cavaliers à ces sites
on ne peut pas prendre le pion bessette
donc marie évidemment ne tombe pas dans
ce piège grossier mais simplement
continue son développement car elle et
ses trois c'est important sans doute de
jouer ce cavalier puisque les noirs
menacé quand même qu'à valises ces deux
attaques la tour à 1 1 et si lecavalier
est encore en b ainsi le cavalier noir
arrivent en c2 et non la tour n'a plus
de casse voilà ça c'est pas une bonne ne
serait pas une bonne nouvelle est vide
et donc il faut sortir ce cavalier mais
dans le cas du câble et c'est de ce
pardon jour tout retour b1 et c'est le
cas les c2 qui risque de se faire
prendre
puisqu'il est trop trop en avant dans le
camp blanc sans menacer quoi que ce soit
ça devenait une pièce difficile à
défendre
donc là les noirs à 6 profite du fait
que toujours pareil dame prend bessette
n'est toujours pas possible tant v8 et
la paix la dame est perdu et à marie est
un peu obligé de jouer le coup suivant
si elle joue elle aurait pu tenter damas
4 mai sur ou d'un psychiatre mais dans
ce cas la b5 probablement sur damas
quatre à homs et classe b celle qui est
noir gagne du temps pour gagner de
l'espace allèles d'âne avec un effet
lissant des cases dans le camp blanc
l'autre mme lacasse et 4 où on peut
envisager m cavalier plus tard donc bon
seul coup à peu près envisageable c'est
ce que je vous marie dans me2 très bien
hélas les noirs un ton coup de
simplification fort je joue donc
l'ukrainienne voyelles se pressent pas
pour développer pour roque et voyelles
que des fois il faut il faut aller
contre les règles de base un bon on
apprend toujours en général aux échecs
que c'est vrai la plupart du temps c'est
vrai il faut sortir ces pièces et rocky
assez vite ce qu'ont fait les blancs
mais parfois il vaut mieux délayé un peu
le rock quand il y a la possibilité de
de harceler la demie et surtout quand le
roi est à l'abri boyer qui sort en noir
bien que n'ayant pas roke risque rien
parce qu'il n'ya pas de colonne ouverte
contre lui
on a vu que les échecs sur la démoniaque
blanche b voilà ça se réduit il ya plus
rien il n'y a plus de fous de cases
blanches
à noter aussi que les noirs ont fait une
bonne affaire puisque en eux ils ont
enlevé leur fou de caisse blanche alors
que tous leurs pions sont sur blanc
quasiment presque tous il ya quelques
temps j'ai cette question noire ce qui
fait que les blancs les noirs avaient un
mauvais fou c'est considéré comme un
mauvais fou quand vous avez le fou sur
la même couleur que vos pions et ici des
pions contrôler les cases blanches à la
place du fou et le fou de cases noires
contrôler les cases de couleurs opposées
voilà donc qui ils ont un jeu très
harmonieux ici les noirs il n'y a pas de
problème et c'est un très bon début de
la part des noirs marie n'a pas réussi à
perturber et l'ukrainienne je vous le
coup fort donc de simplification ici
dans le détroit
alors de mettre en scène sa voix
puissante puisque évidemment le les
changes des dames maintenant et forcée
voilà est sans doute à ce moment là
propose nul puisque la partie termine
ici voilà termine ici par une partie
nulle alors partie de l'anc et ce coup
donc c'est un peu décevant
si on suit évidemment ce match mais
enfin bon ça fait partie des matches des
demi point qu'ils sont bons à prendre ça
permet aux joueuses peut-être de se
reposer un jour de plus puisque hier bon
bain marie a pu se reposer elle n'était
pas elle était pas un tie-break bon
voilà donc elle va pouvoir avoir plein
d'énergie pour la partie revanche ou à
l'oral et noir donc c'est quand même pas
idéal bien sûr mais bon les pentes des
avantages à la fenps eu le bon est ce
que les blancs prendront des risques de
mais c'est pas sûr donc il possible
qu'on aille voilà la probabilité d'un
tailleur et maintenant ils fortin donc
puisque je vous rappelle les deux
joueuses en plus ont un classement assez
assez proche donc même plutôt très
proche et donc de niveau sensiblement
équivalent avec peut-être un petit
avantage à marie mais bon ça reste
théoriquement très léger voilà donc dans
d'étroits bon qu'est ce qu'ils auraient
pu suivre bon pas grand chose a sans
doute un coup comme tour des uns ont été
possibles
même nous sort tout simplement sortir le
fouet trois en trois ça c'est possible
bien sûr voilà et si les noirs par
exemple doubler sur la colonne d où on
change les dames c'est possible aussi
échanger les dames eux jouaient fawcett
et puis rockets il n'y a pas de problème
pour les noirs en terme positionnelle il
ya ils ont bien réussi leur début de
partie
voilà donc
voilà falloir maintenant patienter
suivre le match retour de ces 16e de
finale pouvoir où on est marie bon on
regarde pas encore les les autres
matches a beaucoup trop d'eau match 16e
de finale en seize matches encore 32
joueuses où on est trop tôt pour faire
un bilan des courses on verra ça en
commencera à voir un peu en huitièmes de
finale le tableau résultat mon pression
n'a pas de grandes surprises de toute
façon tout va sur des roulettes en
espérant que bien sûr marie se qualifie
pour les huitièmes de finale avec ce
match retour demain demain samedi
donc un jour un jour de repos
traditionnellement en france et dans les
pays francophones donc de quoi suivre ce
match en direct pourquoi pas et bien sûr
je ferai une petite analyse de cette de
cette partie et puis qu'on peut être un
tie-break dimanche c'est maintenant ça
devient probable cette première partie
nul ça devient la probabilité forte qui
viennent célébrer dimanche avec dont
pascal à des partis sans doute
extrêmement tendue intéressante puisque
ce sera des rapides et en rapide ya en
général pas deux nuls facile ça joue
jusqu'au bout et
il ya des retournements de situation
enfin on n'y est pas marie poussée
pourrait perdre de mer ou gagner ce
qu'on lui souhaite mais sur ce qui
éviterait les tie-breaks voilà donc 16e
de finale terminée pour cette partie
aller et matchs retour à suivre sur des
modèles tv au revoir